Professor David Blight:
Reconstruction is that period of
American history that I think
still--I know still--is
short-shrifted in the ways
people tend to learn American
history in this society,
for whatever the reasons.
Part of the reason may be that
it's messy and complicated,
and part of the reason may be
that it's full of violence,
that it's just not as easy to
find good heroes,
and part of the reason may be
that it comes after such a
total, all out,
and some may say,
in so many ways a glorious war.
Or as Kenneth Stampp,
a great historian,
once put it,
until 1865 there was glory
enough to go around,
but after 1865 where was the
glory?
It's also been a period in
which we've almost insisted--and
I wonder just how you have
learned about this before;
if this were a smaller class I
would ask you--but it's as
though our culture still
insists,
from this period of our
history, that it be a melodrama,
some kind of melodrama with,
well, a sufficient number of
heroes and a sufficient number
of villains, and a melodrama
that usually ends up with a
story of an oppressed South,
much in need of our sympathy.
Now, I've put a piece of words
up here in front of you.
I walked back to see if you
could read it.
I do think most of you in the
room can read it.
Just hold onto the papers until
the end, please.
This is the Thirteenth
Amendment.
We're going to look at the
Thirteenth and the Fourteenth
today, or at least I'll get you
up to the Fourteenth Amendment.
If the Civil War and
Reconstruction were a second
founding--and I'll put the "if"
on that,
although for the next three
weeks I'm going to argue
that--if it was a second
founding,
a second revolution of some
kind, that second founding is in
the Thirteenth,
the Fourteenth,
the Fifteenth Amendments to the
Constitution.
Read the Thirteenth with me.
It's the simplest,
shortest--other than the actual
parts of the Bill of
Rights--it's the simplest,
shortest amendment in the U.S.
Constitution.
It outlaws slavery and
involuntary servitude,
except for imprisonment for
crime.
And then it has that very,
very simple Section Two:
"Congress shall have power to
enforce this article by
appropriate legislation.
That is almost,
in some ways,
a précis for what
Reconstruction will become.
What will constitute
appropriate legislation to
enforce black freedom?
I put it up today in part,
too, because just this weekend
I was out lecturing in
Springfield,
Illinois at the new Abraham
Lincoln Presidential Library;
and it's a magnificent place if
you haven't been there.
It's a museum full of lots of
wax figures.
There's at least one life size
wax of Lincoln in every bloody
room, sometimes two of them,
and then they use holograms and
he appears all over the place.
It's a little weird and scary.
But at the end of the whole day
and evening they took me down in
the vault and asked me if I
wanted to see some special
documents and special
possessions.
They showed me one of Lincoln's
three existing top hats,
they showed me the cast of his
hand;
I got to touch.
They showed me personal notes
he wrote to pardon deserters
from the Union Army.
They showed me all kinds of
things.
But one of the things they
showed me was the original
draft, the handwritten draft by
the clerk of the House of
Representatives,
of the Thirteenth Amendment,
and then signed by "A.
Lincoln" and most of the
members of the House,
at least those who chose to
sign it.
And I realized,
"damn, that thing is real."
And maybe someday I can live to
see the Fourteenth Amendment.
Back to the Fourteenth in a
moment.
Sorry about that,
that's not the Fourteenth
Amendment, that's just the
outline.
Now, a few overall thoughts on
Reconstruction,
to just give you some hooks to
hang your hat on before we look
back again at this question of
Reconstruction during the war,
and then after Lincoln's death
the fight that ensues,
quickly, between the new
president,
Andrew Johnson,
and the Congressional
leadership that the Republican
Party--soon now to be known as
the Radical Republicans--and
what will become a great
constitutional crisis over who
will control Reconstruction and
what Reconstruction will be.
Reconstruction,
though, is often seen--it is
indeed an era of almost
gargantuan aspirations,
if you think about what they
were trying to achieve,
and tragic failures.
But it's also an era of sudden
and unprecedented legal,
political, and constitutional
change.
It's also a period of
tremendous social and political
violence.
We've never experienced
anything in America--other than
sanctioned war,
which the Civil War of course
had been--we've never,
ever experienced social and
political violence on the scale
which you'll see in
Reconstruction.
In fact there's a whole batch
of books coming out now on
Reconstruction violence,
and I suspect this has a lot to
do with living in the age of
terrorism;
publishers are really promoting
the subject.
You're reading one of them
that's just been out a year or
two by Nicholas Lemann called
Redemption.
More on that in a week or two.
In another way,
Reconstruction was one long,
ten, eleven year agonizing
referendum on the meaning of the
war.
What had the war meant?
That's what Reconstruction was
trying to explain,
trying to settle,
trying to codify.
What had actually been the
verdict at Appomattox?
When Lee surrendered and then
Johnston surrendered and the
Confederate Army surrendered,
what was the verdict?
Who got to determine it?
Who had really won the war,
and what had they won?
What cause had lost?
Now, someone really won this
war and someone really lost this
war.
This is not one of those wars
where you can say,
"You know, nobody ever wins a
war."
Nonsense.
Union victory is real,
Confederate defeat was
virtually total,
in a military sense.
But what was the South to lose?
One of the greatest challenges
of Reconstruction was to
determine how you take this
massive,
national blood feud,
of unimaginable scale that's
beginning, and then reconcile it
into a new nation?
The problem,
in part, is that the survivors
on both sides in this war would
still have to inhabit the same
land and the same country.
It wasn't as though an actual
foreign country had been
conquered and defeated.
It was part of North America,
it was part of the U.S.--or
soon to be New U.S.
of some kind.
And the side that lost is going
to have to in time inhabit the
same government.
How?
Where do you go in precedent?
Where do you in history?
Where do you go in the
Constitution?
Where do you look this up,
to put Humpty Dumpty back
together again?
Put another way,
the task was how to make the
eventual logic of sectional
reconciliation--knitting North
and South back together--how to
make the eventual logic of
sectional reconciliation somehow
compatible with the logic of
that revolution that was put in
place in 1863--or in other
words,
Emancipation?
And by logic,
I mean you have to put North
and South back together,
but you also now have to deal
with the fact the slaves have
been freed to some new status.
Got to do both.
Put another way,
how do you square black freedom
and all the stirrings of--the
possibility at least--of racial
equality now with that cause,
in the South,
that had lost
everything--except its faith in
white supremacy?
How do you fold black freedom
into white supremacy?
How do you fold white supremacy
into black freedom?
Can they ever be--could those
ever be reconciled?
And what if they can't?
Lincoln spoke of a testing in
the Gettysburg Address--if you
remember the famous
speech--testing whether that
nation or any nation so
conceived could long endure.
The testing of the war in some
ways would become easier than
the testing the country would
now face with Reconstruction.
Or finally put yet another
way--and I wrote about this at
too much length in a book called
Race and Reunion--the
challenge of Reconstruction,
and it's the challenge we've
had ever since,
is how do you do two profound
things at the same time?
One was healing and the other
was justice.
How do you have them both?
What truly constitutes healing
of a people, of a nation,
that's suffered this scale of
violence and destruction,
and how do you have justice?
And justice for whom?
Here's what Lincoln said,
next-to-the-last day of his
life;
no, three days before he was
shot.
It was his last public
utterance, from a balcony at the
White House.
He was discussing
Reconstruction.
His audience that day wanted to
just hear about the glories of
the ending of the war,
and he gave them a little mini
lecture on Reconstruction
because it's precisely what he
was dealing with.
He said this:
"Reconstruction is pressed much
more closely upon our attention
now.
It is fraught with great
difficulty.
Unlike the case of a war
between independent nations,
there is no authorized organ
for us to treat with.
No one man has authority to
give up the rebellion for any
other man.
We simply must begin with,
and mold from,
disorganized and discordant
elements, with all.
So new and unprecedented is the
whole case that no exclusive and
inflexible plan can safely be
prescribed as to detail,
but important principles must
be inflexible."
That's classic Lincoln.
"No one plan must we
necessarily commit to,
but we must stick to some
principles."
It's Lincoln the pragmatist
trying to figure it out.
And then he's dead.
But back to wartime,
at least for a few minutes.
The debate over Reconstruction,
as it will play out through the
next three years,
four years, really five years,
up to 1870/71,
is the debate that ensued
between Lincoln and his own
party leadership in Congress,
as early as late 1863.
Here's Lincoln's plan again,
and you can read all of this in
Foner's Short
History of
Reconstruction,
but let me give it to you at
least in brief terms.
You'll remember I said the
other day that Lincoln wanted
Reconstruction to be
presidential,
lenient, and quick.
He was openly friendly to
Southerners his whole life,
as I suppose everybody knows.
His four brother-in-laws had
fought for the Confederacy,
et cetera, et cetera.
He was born in Kentucky.
He did not really have any kind
of personal vindictiveness
towards Southerners the way many
others in the Republican Party
will have;
and they'll have reasons to
have that.
Some have argued,
as Kenneth Stampp once did,
that Lincoln actually had a
deep personal need for personal
absolution;
that he carried this horrifying
burden of all that death,
and that he took it as his
personal responsibility,
and that this charity for all
and malice toward none,
and the leniency in Lincoln's
Reconstruction ideas is somehow
rooted in that sense of personal
responsibility for all the
suffering.
There may be something to that.
But his Reconstruction policy,
such as he put it in place,
at least for awhile,
was rooted in his
Constitutional philosophy.
Lincoln, number one,
believed secession had never
happened, that secession was
essentially impossible,
a state could not secede from
the Union.
He chose language carefully,
as a good lawyer.
He said as states,
the Southern states,
the Confederate states,
were still in the Union,
technically,
during the war.
Even though they seceded,
they were simply,
in his language,
out of their normal
relationship to the Union;
whatever the hell that's
supposed to mean.
And they fought this total war
against the United States but
they were not really out of the
Union.
Now that's a legal position,
rest assured.
He made a distinction between
states and governments.
He said that governments may
have failed and committed--he
never used the word
treason--made rebellion against
the United States,
but as states,
an Alabama never ceased to
exist.
Okay.
He's famous for saying things
like "physically we cannot
separate."
His idea was to squash the
rebellion, let a number of loyal
citizens, in one of those
seceded states,
create a new loyal government,
restore that state to the Union
as quickly as possible,
even before the war ends,
by presidential authority,
under presidential war powers,
and begin a process before
you'd ever have a surrender of
what he was already calling
restoration,
or reunification.
He wanted it done by executive
authority.
That wasn't necessarily a
personal power grab by any means
but he wanted to do it under
presidential war powers,
because he did understand,
to the extent anybody could
predict the future,
that once the war did end,
Congress's powers would rise.
A president is never so
powerful as in time of war.
Now, pause with me for a moment.
What they're all thinking about
now--Lincoln,
the Republican leadership of
Congress,
anybody thinking about
Reconstruction,
during the war or even in the
immediate aftermath--is really
thinking about a set of
questions,
somewhat like those big
questions I started with,
but more specifically.
This is what they have to think
about now.
And if you think American
statesmen have been challenged
at other times in our history,
how would you like to have this
challenge?
Three main questions.
(1) Who would rule in the
South, who?
Who gets to vote?
Who gets to hold office;
ex-Confederates,
black people,
whites who'd been loyal?
How do you determine this?
(2) Who will rule in the
federal government,
Congress or the President,
in this unprecedented blank
slate set of issues?
The country had never faced
this before.
How do you reconstruct a Union?
How do you re-admit states into
the Union?
There's no blueprint in the
Constitution.
There are hints,
depending on how you interpret
it.
And (3) what will the
dimensions of black freedom be,
in law and in practice and in
social life, on the ground,
in the South?
All the while remembering this
all must occur now in these
desperate conditions of poverty,
destruction,
starvation and tremendous
untold, as yet not even fully
fathomed,
bitterness and hatred.
Or let me give you one last
little question.
I love asking questions I don't
have to stand up right now and
answer.
Would Reconstruction be a
preservation of something old,
or the creation of something
truly new?
And if it's going to be new,
how new?
Back to the war years.
Lincoln issued,
on December 8,1863,
his State of the Union or
annual message--part of his
annual message--what he called
the Proclamation of Amnesty and
Reconstruction.
It was issued December '63.
Remember the dates here,
because this first major debate
on Reconstruction is going to
occur in some of the most
terrible months of the war,
and yet in Washington they're
also having this debate.
There were several parts to
this, but three main ones.
It's Lincoln's classic lenient,
rapid, moderate and
presidential Reconstruction.
It's called the Ten-Percent
Plan.
He, number one,
would pardon all
ex-Confederates,
with a certain list of
exceptions.
High-ranking Confederate
officials--although he didn't
entirely clarify how high
ranking--they wouldn't be
pardoned, at least yet.
He would not pardon those who
had resigned commissions in the
judiciary or in Congress,
to support the Confederacy.
And he put in a clause that
said he would not pardon those
who could be convicted of
mistreating black soldiers,
of which there'd been a great
deal of, and he was under some
pressure to do something about
that,
by late '63.
And then he said when ten
percent of the voting population
of a given Southern state--and
that voting population was
determined by how many voters in
1860--when ten percent of the
male voting population--because
that's the only people who could
vote--would take an oath to the
Union and establish a new
government,
then he as president,
under presidential war powers,
would recognize them and
readmit them to the Union,
just like that.
Blacks were excluded from the
entire process.
There was no mention,
at that point,
of any black suffrage.
He wants ten percent.
Now, right away members of his
own party and Congress are
saying, "Wait a second Mr.
President, what about the other
ninety percent?"
Well Lincoln's idea was if you
can establish a pocket of people
in lower Louisiana or upland
Alabama,
or part of Virginia that the
Union troops occupy,
and you get,
if you can get ten percent of
that state to take a loyalty
oath and elect some kind of
little rump legislature that can
meet somewhere,
like Wheeling,
West Virginia,
where they did for awhile,
then he would call that the
real Virginia,
or the real Louisiana,
and they'd be back in the
Union.
And his idea was that you would
begin then a political process
of reunification.
A political process would
already be in place,
as messy as it might be,
as seemingly undemocratic as it
might be, before the war would
end.
This actually happened.
Well he didn't--they didn't get
admitted to the Union,
but so-called Lincoln
governments were established in
three states,
again where Union armies had
significant occupation of the
soil of that state--Louisiana,
Tennessee and Arkansas--and
so-called Lincoln governments
were created there,
in 1864 and early 1865.
They were pitifully weak
governments.
They would've collapsed
entirely without federal troops
to protect them,
and Lincoln did this utterly
without consulting with
Congress.
And we like to make a great
deal of Abraham Lincoln as the
greatest president,
and he was;
a political genius, and he was;
magical with the music of
words, and he was;
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And I was just out at the
Lincoln Library where you can be
sure Lincoln is God.
But not consulting with
Congress on this one wasn't the
wisest thing he ever did.
Congress began to react with
great hostility,
in 1864.
Some Radical Republicans
sincerely believed that these
new Lincoln governments were not
only wrong and undemocratic,
but dangerous,
and they wanted much,
much more to even consider the
reconstruction of a Southern
state,
on any basis.
They were led--they being the
Republicans in Congress--by the
two men on your right,
Thaddeus Stevens on the top and
Charles Sumner on the bottom.
Stevens, a Congressman from
Pennsylvania who grew up and
lived near Gettysburg;
fascinating,
interesting,
driven, passionate,
complicated,
club-footed man;
a brilliant lawyer,
and a radical,
and an old abolitionist,
although he had some
complications along the way.
Stevens and Sumner.
Sumner the great Senator from
Massachusetts--the Sumner who
had had the brains nearly beaten
out of him by Preston Brooks in
the Senate in 1856,
who left the Senate for nearly
three and a half years and went
all over the world to spas to
try to put his head back
together,
including spending most of a
year in Switzerland--was very,
very much back in the game
during the war;
and he rose in power,
of course, as the emancipation
issue rose to the fore,
as did Stevens.
And the two of them led the
response to Lincoln's ideas on
Reconstruction from the two
different houses of Congress.
They had different names for
their proposals,
but they essentially argued the
same thing;
although Sumner's,
you could argue,
was even more radical.
Stevens called his approach,
or his constitutional approach,
conquered provinces.
He said not only did the
Southern states secede from the
Union, they should be reverted
to the status of unorganized
territories;
or, even further he went,
he said now they're not only
going to have to be put under
territorial status,
but they should be treated like
a foreign nation that the United
States has conquered,
a conquered province of a
foreign land.
They had been reduced by force
of arms, they had made war upon
the United States,
and under international law,
Stevens argued,
they should be treated as,
quote,
his words, "conquered foreign
land," subject to whatever the
United States shall choose to do
with it.
Sumner, for his part,
called this theory--it was even
more direct--State Suicide.
That was pretty clear.
He said not only had the
Southern states seceded from the
Union, they committed political
suicide.
They do not exist.
They experienced what he
called, in his words,
"instant forfeiture of their
status as states."
They therefore must be reverted
to what he called "the status of
unorganized territories,"
as though Alabama was back in
1820, Virginia was back in 1787,
or whatever year they
officially became a state--I'm
sorry,
before that even,
during the Revolution.
And therefore,
in both cases,
Stevens or Sumner's plan,
all authority to re-admit any
Southern state or determine the
process,
the means by which,
the laws by which a state would
be re-instituted into the Union,
came under Congressional
authority because only Congress
has the power to readmit new
states.
Take that, Abraham Lincoln.
They issued this theory to
Lincoln in what was known as the
Wade-Davis Bill in July--4^(th)
of July to be exact--1864.
Note the date.
This is in the midst of the
stalemate in Virginia;
it's just after Cold Harbor;
Grant has just begun to put
Petersburg under siege;
the terrible bloodletting in
Virginia is coming in and the
thousands and thousands of names
on casualty lists,
and Congress issues what's
known as the Wade-Davis Bill,
named for Senator Benjamin Wade
of Ohio,
a strong anti-slavery Radical
Republican, and Henry Winter
Davis, a Congressman from
Maryland,
also of at least moderate
anti-slavery credentials.
What you have here is the
blueprint of Radical
Reconstruction,
at least the beginning
blueprint.
The Wade-Davis Bill said,
they took--the first part of
it--was they took Lincoln's
Ten-Percent idea,
ten percent of the voting
population of a Southern state,
and they required a majority of
white male citizens of a
Southern state who must,
secondly, take what the
Radicals called an Ironclad
Oath, and that oath said that
they had to get up and swear
they had never participated in
the Confederate war effort or
aided and abetted it.
Now, immediately you're
wondering how in hell are you
going to find a majority of the
white males of Georgia,
or Alabama, or Mississippi,
or any other Confederate state
that can get up and take that
oath?
The answer is you couldn't.
To the congressional leadership
that was just fine for now.
The Ironclad Oath was a
political message,
it was a symbolic oath.
They knew you'd never get a
majority of whites who could
take this.
The third part,
they said all officers above
the rank of lieutenant,
and all civil officers of all
kinds in the Confederacy would
not only be not pardoned,
they would be disfranchised
forever, declared not--the
actual language in the bill was,
"not a citizen of the United
States."
It was almost as though they
were giving every office holder,
every officer,
lieutenant and above,
who was still alive in the
South, an invitation to leave
the country,
because if they stayed in
America they would be men
without a country.
They did not set up,
in spite of the lore that's set
in over the years,
a plan of arrest,
indictments,
and executions.
They didn't do that at all.
But they did decide they were
going to treat the Southern
states as conquered enemies.
They sent the bill to Lincoln,
and Lincoln did what many
presidents have done,
he gave it a pocket veto.
You know what that is.
He simply let the bill die
without either signing it,
or vetoing it,
or to some extent even
answering it;
although he did finally answer
it.
He answered it actually four
days after the bill was
delivered to him,
in what he titled "The
Proclamation on the Wade-Davis
Bill."
And this was a classic
Lincolnesque statement as well.
It was conciliatory.
He thanked them profusely for
their work on this sensitive and
terrible issue,
and he didn't completely reject
it.
He refused, he said,
to be, quote,
"inflexibly committed to any
one plan."
"Okay Abe, but what are you
committed to?"
is what congressmen began to
say.
He was verbally willing to
listen, but he really did not
placate the Radicals.
They had an impasse here,
a big impasse.
And note how deep the impasse
is, it's constitutional.
Who's going to run
Reconstruction?
Me, the president,
or you the Congress?
Well, the congressional
leadership followed Lincoln's
little Proclamation on the
Wade-Davis Bill with what they
called The Wade-Davis Manifesto,
and they published it in
national newspapers.
It was published on August
5,1864.
It was an unprecedented,
vehement attack on a sitting
president by the leadership in
Congress of his own party.
They lambasted Lincoln.
They attacked him on two
grounds.
They said his approach to
Reconstruction was simply way
too lenient--and they're arguing
this now in August of 1864,
with these thousands upon
thousands of casualties flowing
in.
This is the very time Lincoln
comes to believe he's not likely
to be re-elected.
And there were some members in
particularly the Radical wing of
the Republican Party who'd been
laboring to dump Lincoln from
the ticket all summer,
and probably could've succeeded
in doing it if there wasn't so
much at stake.
And they went a second step.
They actually accused him of
usurpation of presidential
powers, an impeachable offense
if anyone ever cared to take it
any further step.
Here's the key,
as the dispute emerged that
summer.
Lincoln viewed Reconstruction
as a means to weakening the
Confederacy and winning the war.
Think of it as a political
strategy, that ten percent idea,
trying to get some fledgling
little state legislature and
government,
somehow get two or three of
them into the Union.
It was a strategy,
and not a blueprint written in
stone for the way Reconstruction
would always be.
But to the Radical Republicans,
they viewed this as a much more
far-reaching transformation in a
building really of a new nation,
when and if they could win the
war.
They really were at an impasse.
Now you know from our previous
lectures and your reading that
the fall of Mobile Bay on August
5,
the same day as the Wade-Davis
Manifesto, Admiral Farragut took
Mobile Bay.
That had a tremendous impact on
public opinion.
Then on September 3 or 4
Atlanta fell.
It had an even greater impact
on public opinion.
And of course you've got the
presidential race now happening
in the fall, and Lincoln is
re-elected.
This impasse on Reconstruction,
though, basically just sat
there until Lincoln's death.
In the meantime he cooperated,
and so did they,
on two tremendous pieces of
legislation, on two great
enactments.
One is the Thirteenth
Amendment, which we just
discussed;
and I want to come back to that
in a moment.
Well actually I'll mention it
now.
The fact that it got passed is
fairly remarkable;
that it got passed at all is
fairly remarkable.
It is, first of all,
an amendment that Lincoln
himself by late '64 began to
advocate,
especially after his
re-election, vehemently
advocate, and it's something
exactly that the Radical
Republicans want.
They were absolutely on the
same page on it.
And the reason Lincoln
was--well he had moral reasons
to believe slavery should now be
eradicated in the Constitution,
make no mistake.
But he also had reason to want
this Constitutional Amendment
because he feared,
and rightly so,
that if the war ended,
with only the Emancipation
Proclamation as the legal
sanction for all those freed
slaves,
that there would be nothing to
stop Southerners from thousands
upon thousands of law suits in
federal courts,
suing under Fifth Amendment for
their property.
And it would've--it did happen,
to some extent anyway,
but if you can get it in the
Constitution as a constitutional
amendment,
then they would have no right
to sue for property that is no
longer property.
So a lot was at stake.
They wanted a Thirteenth
Amendment because of the
potential invalidity of the
Emancipation Proclamation
legally;
they wanted to remove legal
doubt.
And you'll remember that the
Proclamation had only freed
slaves in the states in
rebellion.
Technically slaves in Kentucky,
Missouri, Delaware,
Maryland, were still in a kind
of limbo.
It passed the House of
Representatives on January
31,1865, but it was not easy.
You might think you live in the
United States of America and of
course there'd be a Thirteenth
Amendment--finally,
of course, we would outlaw
slavery in the Constitution.
The vote was 119 to 56;
it passed by two votes--it
takes a two-thirds majority for
a constitutional amendment--it
passed by two votes.
Lincoln began to twist arms;
he began to have personal
meetings with a select little
list of Democrats.
They didn't have a two-thirds
majority of Republicans.
They needed some Democrats to
vote for this.
And by far the majority of
Democrats wanted nothing to do
with outlawing slavery in the
Constitution,
but about eight of them came
over.
And on the day that it was
passed there was unprecedented
rejoicing in the House of
Representatives.
The whole hall was full;
congressmen,
we're told, started yelling,
crying, hugging each other,
dancing on the tops of their
desks--God knows why,
in part because of the
importance, the gravity of the
issue, and in part perhaps
because they'd lived through so
much agony in the war,
they truly had something to
celebrate.
You have to go to individual
diaries and letters to really
see it.
There was a Republican who
recorded in his diary that day,
quote, "Members joined in the
shouting and kept it up for some
minutes.
Some embraced one another.
Others wept like children.
I have felt ever since the vote
as though I live in a new
country."
Frederick Douglass's son,
Lewis, veteran of the 54^(th)
Massachusetts,
in his uniform was sitting in
the balcony, on the afternoon
the Thirteenth Amendment was
passed.
His father was back home in
Rochester.
He immediately wrote his father
a note, that I've read.
It said, "Father,
you should've been here today.
Today was your day."
And then at the same time that
Congress, with Lincoln's strong
approval, worked on a bill to
create the Freedmen's Bureau,
an unprecedented agency in
American history,
certainly to that time.
Formerly called the Bureau of
Refugees, Freedmen and Abandoned
Lands, it passed Congress on the
3^(rd) of March,
1865, just a day before
Lincoln's Second Inaugural.
It was social reform by
military force.
Americans had never done this
before--a national,
federal, social welfare agency,
in a land that had lived and
breathed laissez-faire
government;
in a land that had lived and
breathed this idea that
governments don't provide food
for people, people provide food
for people, healthcare,
schools.
Well the war,
of course, had forced a new
kind of history.
The basic purposes of the
Freedmen's Bureau,
when it was set up,
was to aid refugees and
displaced people,
black or white.
And the estimate--and I may
have used this before--the
estimate on the ground in the
South,
by late winter 1865,
was that there were at least a
quarter million totally
displaced starving white people;
much less the four million soon
to be liberated slaves.
The Freedmen's Bureau was to
provide all kinds of physical
supplies, medical services,
schools where it could.
Its purpose was also legal,
to supervise contracts between
freedmen and employees--more on
that later.
And its job--and this was an
impossible task--but its job and
its title was to manage
confiscated and abandoned land.
Yes, property.
But who really owns it now?
If the Union Army took your
plantation, who owns it?
And there is nothing more
primal, of course,
especially to Americans,
than property.
Now, more on the Freedmen's
Bureau later,
but it was a terribly important
piece of legislation.
It passed with majorities in
both houses, of course,
because the Republicans had
those majorities,
and Lincoln gladly signed it,
and it established,
at least, an agency to be put
in place once the war was over.
Now, let me take the last few
minutes and set up what is now
to happen between old Andrew
Johnson and this same leadership
of the Radical Republicans once
Lincoln was gone.
This is the classic struggle of
Reconstruction,
Johnson and the Radicals.
Now first of all,
how did Andrew Johnson get on
Lincoln's ticket?
Why did Abraham Lincoln choose
Andrew Johnson as his running
mate?
I've often put this to major
Lincoln scholars.
Now look, I confess,
I'm a great admirer of Lincoln,
like most people.
But he couldn't do everything
perfectly.
And he gave us Andrew Johnson,
and we've never held him
responsible for that.
And I'm not willing to give him
a total pass on that one,
because Andrew Johnson ranks
down there just about minus two
on the list of presidents,
I think, of all time.
Well how's that for directness?
Sorry about that.
If you're an Andrew Johnson
fan, you're lonely.
[laughter]
He's on the ticket in '64
because--you know this?--he's
the only senator from a seceded
Confederate state who didn't
secede with a state.
He stayed in the Union,
from Tennessee.
He's a complicated guy.
God, he could've been
interesting.
He had some big flaws.
I'm going to leave you with a
little background on Andrew
Johnson.
As you can tell from the
syllabus I've put myself nearly
a full lecture behind in the
course,
but don't you worry,
because we're planning for
Reading Week a special review
session when I can give another
lecture.
Aren't you happy?
There's an old saying about
Andrew Johnson that,
quote, "old Andy never went
back on his raisin'," his
raising up.
He's from East Tennessee.
He was born in North Carolina.
He grew up illiterate.
He once owned eleven slaves,
although he did free them.
He moved to East Tennessee with
his wife, Polly,
who taught him his literacy.
He grew up a Jacksonian
Democrat.
His God was Andrew Jackson.
If lovers of the New Deal
believe FDR was somehow the son
of God, as my grandparents did,
Andrew Johnson thought Andrew
Jackson was the son of God.
In 1861 he was the only
Southern senator who did not
secede with his state.
In 1862 Lincoln appointed him
the War Governor of Tennessee,
in the occupied parts of
Tennessee,
out of which Lincoln eventually
was going to--he did try to
create a new government.
Andrew Johnson was his governor.
It took tremendous courage to
be a Unionist in Tennessee
during the Civil War.
There was a lot of Unionism in
East Tennessee,
and in '64 Lincoln needed a
border state running mate.
After all, who had been his
running mate before?
Totally forgettable I realize;
no one ever remembers the
vice-presidents from--anybody
remember vice-presidents from
the twentieth century?
Only those who get Nobel Prizes
do we really remember I guess.
But Hannibal Hamlin of New
Hampshire had been Lincoln's
running mate.
Now what good is a New
Hampshirite on the ticket in
'64?
A New Hampshirite was useful in
'60 but not in '64.
So he dumps Hannibal Hamlin,
in spite of the alliteration of
his name, and goes for a
political choice.
What could send a better
Unionist message to the border
states than Andrew Johnson,
the only Southern senator who
doesn't secede from his seat?
Well, all was pretty well,
at least until the
inauguration.
Andrew Johnson,
unfortunately,
was drunk at his inauguration
as Vice-President of the United
States.
Now his explanation for that is
that he had a terrible tooth
infection and he'd been sloshing
down whiskey all morning.
But they literally had to stand
him up, prop him up and point
him in the right direction,
and practically raise his hand.
On the day he was inaugurated,
when Lincoln delivered the
Second Inaugural,
AJ had to be removed to a back
room.
Not an auspicious beginning.
Last thought.
By far the most important thing
about Andrew Johnson though,
in spite of his early comments
when he said,
"Treason must be made odious,"
and Charles Sumner said,
"Oh, he's speaking my
language,"
the thing we must know about
Andrew Johnson is number one,
he was a virulent white
supremacist,
he was an ardent states'
rightist.
Yes he was a states' rightist
and a Unionist.
It's entirely possible to be
that.
He also hated the southern
planter class.
He was never anti-slavery.
He was not only not
anti-slavery,
he was an open racist.
He believed the United States
should remain,
in his own words,
"a white man's country
forever."
And he had a disposition that
could best charitably be
described as hypersensitive and
obstinate.
He was not a flexible
politician.
Well, I'll leave you with old
Andrew Johnson,
now into the story and messing
things up, and I'll see you
Thursday.